[Music]
hello film cage fans my name is David
Brandon hello my name is Karen won I'm
your other co-host from La talk radio
filmage right now I'm at the downtown
independent in Los Angeles and you know
what Karen and I um the lovely Karen
Warden who's holding the camera right
now we won this care package so we had
this gift bag here and it's almost like
Christmas morning I'm going to open it
and see what's in here this care package
from Bill osto and first glance films
which is taking place this weekend at
Raleigh Studios April 9th through the
11th and um this also comes courtesy of
film snoby Nick basley Jerry cavalero
and we don't want to keep this we want
to give this away to you and we're going
to do it right here at our next film C
interactive um and we're going to share
with you what's inside and hopefully
there'll be a little way to entice you
to come out have some fun with us here
at our next film cage interactive April
um 20 26 6 April 26 of downtown andent
we're going to be screening The Water
Hole actually come with me right now
we're screening The Water Hole April
26th this is Nathan Cole right there
wait there we
go H happy hour is over
right here downtown
independent April 26th um and we're
going to be giving away some War prizes
why don't we dive in to see what we're
going to be giving away looks like first
off it's a t-shirt of some sort very
nice oh look at that it's a first glance
Film Festival t-shirt nice big size
there nice and roomy very
nice we
[Applause]
have this okay okay a year subscription
to Movie Maker magazine got a few of
them how many do we have
um looks like at least
10 so courtesy of first glance films
very nice great publication Make
magazine oo some
software Sony Vegas movie studio
[Music]
okay real production calendar
last but not
least gorilla professional
Edition so these are all the wonderful
little giveaways that will be at the
next film courage interactive which is
Monday April 26 at the beautiful
downtown independent and again we will
be showing Nathan Kohl's The Water Hole
so we'll see you then at 700 p.m. look
that
rhy
[Applause]